Okay, so we got four points on a graph, let's fill in a few more and see if a shape starts to emerge.
I want to know when X=1/2 Xmax, so that would correspond to this position right here
or this position here on the graph and the mass is moving to the right,
what is V/Vmax.
Now you maybe thinking but Andy, you haven't given me k, you haven't given me Xmax.
How can I calculate anything? Well, you have two options--
You could make up those values and I promise you when you calculate this out
it won't matter what values you chose or you can just manipulate these algebraic symbols
until you solve for V/Vmax.
That could be a little trickier--you've either option to shot.
I know they are both tough. If you need help, don't be discouraged.
These are tricky topics we're dealing with. Feel free to go to the forums.